it seems like you are now the guy that
everyone goes to we rom-coms it's like
Noah and rom-coms are a thing that be
caught up Noah sent nao is trading in
those rom coms for some time as a super
hero the 22 year old actor confirmed
some big news on Mondays Tonight Show
Starring Jimmy Fallon is this a true
rumor I heard that you might be are you
playing he-man yes feel like it's
happening fast yeah Prince of Eternia
and defender of the secrets of Castle
Grayskull the he-man reboot is said to
be based on the original he-man and the
Masters of the Universe story which
launched the super popular animated TV
series in the early 80s it's already
been confirmed that Noah is reprising
his role as Pierre Kavinsky
in the - all the boys I've loved before
sequel what currently and it's turning
out to be a one busy year for the
heartthrob as he'll also be in the
Charlie's Angels reboot later this year
when 80 spoke with Noah on the heels of
his Ciara Burges is a loser success he
opened up about exploring darker
characters I'd love to turn around and
do something else I think there's a good
way to segue into different roles in
different genres not opposed to shaving
my head and like doing something Caillou
you